what's the deal are you going to leave
after this season i've been talking to
che about it in general
i'm not sure i think this the covid
stuff has really affected
how i feel about it because you know
being away from
people that make you laugh uh you know
at work in that way
for this long is really makes you
appreciative
of not only the job but of the routine
of being
at work and having to run into people
who are funny like in the hallways
and how much of of that how much of the
the joy of the job is just proximity
you know you're you have to be with
people you love and uh right
you know and without that routine you
you could be in la and you could go
months without seeing friends and and
you're much more isolated
whereas at our job you have nowhere to
hide you have to see your friends it's
great
and you know what else is weird about a
gig on saturday night live i mean
it's such a great gig and you know it
but it almost seems to me that when
people get hired there they off to
almost
from the beginning begin to plot when
they're going to leave yeah you have an
anxiety do you have an anxiety to
do you know do other things and kind of
like prove your worth in another way
but you know i think the thing that
lauren says is like people who you love
who used to be cast members on snl
the funniest they ever were was on snl
like even even they even if they did
great brilliant work after
that there was something about the first
time you discovered them
and saw them on snl like the first times
you see
will ferrell you know he's made such
funny movies
but there's there's also just that thing
about the first glimpse you got of will
ferrell
yelling at a dinner table or something
it's like this pure
thing the best versions of that are
probably people kind of [ __ ] around
and finding something that's really
funny to them or makes their friends
laugh
and there's something loose and and very
pure about it because you're
it's not structured in a movie or it's
not you know whatever it's just
it's just like trying to make people
laugh for four minutes